Quantum algorithms complexity and fall
tolerance which will run concurrently
with the error correcting program and
I'm looking forward to stepping out of
my role as associate director and being
a a scientific visitor and participant
in that program uh it's co-organized by
Anor Anu niik Brookman ARA Mahadev o who
you heard from earlier and myself um so
as quantum computers are being built
with a thousand plus cubits um theory is
really having an increasingly important
role and it's been really exciting with
this fledging industry to see how um the
tight dialogue between Academia and
Industry because the field is really so
young we have a really important role to
play um uh cubits by their nature are
very faulty so building fault tolerance
is a is a Holy Grail right now and it's
an important milestone in the
development of the field um com
computational complexity has played an
important role in the proof of
quantumness and de demonstrating quantum
Advantage how do we really know that
these quantum computers are doing some
something fundamentally different than
what classical computers can do um and
of course the development of quantum
algorithms how can we harness these
machines to perform useful tasks um so
the overlap with error correcting codes
will be particularly exciting and um
there's been a lot of really big
developments on the theory side with the
development of quantum low low density
parity check codes with uh optimal
parameters but it's still far from being
realized in practice we still have to
develop efficient decoding algorithms
compute on uh encoded data and we're
still a ways away from actual fault to
tolerant protocol protocols in a in a
practical setting so um we'll also have
a Quantum complexity will play an
important role in this in this program
um we have a a theory sort of analog an
analogous to NP completeness in the
quantum World um but what we don't have
is a good understanding of the theory of
approximation which has been so
influential in classical complexity so
the quantum PCP conjecture is one of the
big open problems in the field and it
asks is it hard to approximate um basic
problems of uh basic properties of
quantum systems um in addition to that
uh the overlap between Quantum Computing
and cryptography will play an important
role as well as you know modern
cryptographic protocols Ry on the
hardness of problems that we believe
that quantum computers will be able to
crack so we have to develop postquantum
cryptography so uh cryptographic
protocols that will be robust in the
presence of quantum computers and also
cryptography has played an important
role in how a classical limited verifier
can communicate with a quantum computer
and verify quantumness and verify the
computation so there's a lot of exciting
roles for Theory to play in this field
um and as usual we'll bring in our
cohort of physicists mathematicians
computer scientists for a very exciting
and full semester so looking forward to
that and I think gillan's up
[Applause]
next